on his first full day in Canada Pope
Francis delivered a historic apology for
the quote evil committed by so many
Christians against indigenous people his
week-long trip centers around his
response to the treatment of indigenous
children at government-funded schools
the majority ran by Catholics from the
1800s to the 1900s Chris livesay is
traveling with the Pope
right of a former parential School in
the Canadian city of masquatchies Pope
Francis was greeted with sacred drumming
and dance rituals the church once sought
to erase
it was here the pope issued a historic
apology to a crowd of thousands most of
them indigenous people I am here because
the first step of my penitential
pilgrimage among you is that of again
asking forgiveness
that apology was met with Applause from
the crowd as was this request I ask
forgiveness people were visibly
emotional wiping their tears the pope
was given a traditional headdress to
wear after his remarks the pope began
the Day visiting what is believed to be
a graveyard for some of the children who
never made it home for around a century
more than 150 000 native children were
taken from their families to attend
government-funded residential schools
most of them run by the Catholic Church
they faced rampant neglect physical and
sexual abuse while being forced to
assimilate Richard green spent nine
years in a residential school his
parents had also been forced to attend
an apology won't erase anything The
Experience already happened the Catholic
church was invested in cultural genocide
historian candida Moss is a professor of
theology what Pope Francis hasn't done
so far is he hasn't admitted that the
Catholic church has a sort of systemic
role in the way that indigenous people
have been treated in Canada and in the
cultural genocide that took place in
these institutions of education for CBS
mornings Chris livesay Edmonton Canada